[Música]
bueno muchas gracias a todos por esperar
tantas horas
esta historia que les voy a contar
empezó en la década de los 60 es decir
hace ya más de 60 años
mi papá a quien siempre llamamos papá
ya fallecido
fue médico estudió medicina en la
universidad de antioquia fue muy buen
estudiante y se ganó una beca para ir a
los eeuu a filadelfia a especializarse
en gastroenterología
los contabas cómo llegó a barranquilla
como acuatizó o como sin saber una sola
palabra de inglés llegó a una
universidad en filadelfia y
efectivamente se graduó como médico
gastroenterólogo
perteneció a la bogus international
society que es la sociedad especializada
en gastroenterología
y resolvió regresar a medellín y poner
su consultorio privado
empezó a trabajar
y contaba que un día recibió una llamada
del señor bocuse que era el director de
la sociedad tenga su intro logía que le
dijo doctor vélez
quiero pedirle un favor
nos están buscando de cuba para que
dictemos una conferencia sobre el avance
de la basó en tecnología
él me decía que se sintió orgullosísimo
y no podía creer que nunca jamás iba a
recibir esa llamada de su profesor
estamos hablando hace 60 años cuando no
había computadores no había power point
no había internet él tenía que
todos sus libros en inglés y traducirlos
a un español perfecto para llegar a cuba
contaba entonces que llegó a cuba que
llegó a cuba emocionadísimo
hizo un esfuerzo enorme para darle mejor
conferencia sobre cómo había avanzado la
gastroenterología en el mundo y uno de
los estudiantes al final alzó la mano y
le dice doctor yo le pregunto
para qué sirve la gastroenterología en
una isla como cuba en la de la que sólo
el 10% de la población tiene acceso a
agua potable
él contaba que a su regreso
esa idea le quedó taladrando es decir
para que la ciencia
si no tiene en cuenta la comunidad en la
cual aplicamos esa ciencia
porque me vengo triste de cuba si en
medellín la ciudad que tanto quiero
sucede lo mismo
renunció a la práctica de su medicina
y llegó a ser alcalde de medellín con
una sola obsesión como vamos a lograr el
mayor acceso de agua potable a la
población
ese programa en su momento se llamó
habilitación vivienda y hoy es un
programa que sigue vigente y con
seguridad durante muchos años más el
gran reto de todos los líderes será el
acceso de agua potable para la comunidad
oyéndole esta historia que él siempre
decía es que si tenemos el poder es para
transformar la realidad
quise traerles hoy dos ejemplos voy a
hablarles de dos temas totalmente
distintos esta es una imagen de la
central hidroeléctrica de itaipú
la central hidroeléctrica de itaipú en
balsa el río paraná que es un río el 80
por ciento de su recorrido está en
brasil y sólo el 10 por ciento está en
paraguay es el segundo río más grande de
américa latina
también en los años 60 el presidente de
brasil
jocelyn o kubitschek como todos los
portugueses que dicen o más grande del
mundo él dijo yo quiero hacer la represa
más grande del planeta
usted dijo yo solía no coche por allá en
el año 60 estando en aquellas encontró
que el 15% de ese río pertenece al país
más pequeño de américa latina a paraguay
pues sí señor tuvo que sentarse con el
presidente de paraguay a hablar con el
presidente de paraguay sobre la represa
de itaipú
se soñaron una central hidroeléctrica de
20 unidades de generación de energía
14.000 megavatios
ustedes se preguntarán eso qué es esa es
la energía que consume colombia entera
en un año y hacer el sueño de kubitschek
según todo con paraguay arrancan la
negociación con paraguay
y siete años después logran el primer
acuerdo siete años después de
negociaciones
pues les cuento que la primera unidad de
generación se demoró 14 años en entrar
en funcionamiento y estamos enfrentados
enfrentados a 20 unidades de generación
cuando entré a la primera unidad de
generación de dice argentina a pérez que
el río paraná
desemboca en el río de la plata' y
ustedes le tienen que ayudar a mí a
mantener el flujo del río de la plata
para que el momento coincidencialmente
los tres presidentes argentina brasil y
uruguay eran dictadores alfredo
strossner el presidente de paraguay es
durante 35 años y cuando le dijeron
usted no puede instalar la segunda
central como así que no la puede
instalar pues tuvo que entender siendo
dictador que se tenía que sentar con una
argentina a negociar la instalación de
las 19 que le faltaba
esa central de itaipú es agua al final
en lo que muchos conocemos como foz de
iguazú las cataratas que tienen la
belleza de ser hoy una de las siete
maravillas del mundo
esto lo hago simplemente para como para
que relacione donde está ubicada
y se esta cuenta
43 presidentes entre los de brasil
argentina y paraguay han tenido que
intervenir 43 para que sólo en el año 13
entrará en funcionamiento la número 20
43 presidentes 54 años entonces yo me
pregunto
cómo se da la transformación
cuántos conocimientos tienen que
intervenir para que un proyecto esto sea
cierto
entre ingenieros geólogos sociólogos
ecologistas cuánto conocimiento cuantas
acciones cuantas veces estos presidentes
tuvieron que cambiar sus planes sus
estrategias modificarlas para llegar
para que finalmente hoy brasil y
paraguay tengan la represa más grande
del mundo eso es hoy una realidad pero
han pasado 54 años
traigo otro ejemplo muy pequeño pero que
lo llevo en el alma
lo que ustedes ven ahí es el sistema de
transporte masivo que llega al parque
arví
el parque arví también tiene una
historia en sus orígenes fue la primera
central hidroeléctrica que tuvo medellín
que se llamó la central de santa elena y
estuvo 30 años en operación generando en
energía a los 30 años pasó a ser un
embalse y fue el principal proveedor de
agua potable de medellín por más de 50
años y se llamó el embalse de piedras
blancas
de manera casual
estando yo muy joven tenía 21 años mi
marido que también falleció fue alcalde
y en las conversaciones con mi papá
mi papá le decía josé jaime qué sentido
tiene que hayan 10.000 hectáreas
cerradas con alambres de púas para una
comunidad que lo que necesita es
recreación hay que abrir eso hay que
entregárselo a la comunidad eso no puede
estar cerrado
y eso se los estoy hablando en el año 80
tuve la suerte de trabajar en empresas
públicas de medellín como secretaria
general y esa fue la obsesión como le
entregamos a la comunidad
diez mil hectáreas de parque para que
disfruten de la naturaleza y conserven
la naturaleza
pues tengo que decirles que lo logramos
desde el año 2007 existe lo que todos
conocemos como el parque arví en ese año
se logró que el metro de medellín
comunicará por el sistema de transporte
público la llegada hasta el parque arví
hoy tenemos más de un millón casi un
millón de visitantes al año
pero es una verdadera transformación es
una verdadera transformación
de las historias que más me impactan de
cuando inició el parque arví es que
ustedes todos saben aquí que es un
sancocho un sancocho es esa sopa que
tiene que tener gallina grasa hígados
yuca una cantidad de cosas y resulta que
se sube al sistema de transporte al
metrocable un señor con dos gallinas
vivas les voy a subir al cambio desde el
operador del cable le dice señor en el
sistema no está permitido viajar con
animales vivos el inicio hay que
importar del cuerpo el pescuezo
yo voy es hacer sancocho
cierto así arrancamos en el parque arví
así arrancamos hoy espero que muchos
hayan visitado pero hoy es un espacio
real esparcimiento respeto por la
naturaleza avistamiento de aves y quiero
decir les faltan muchos años mucho
trabajo muchas generaciones para que el
parque arví tenga la infraestructura y
lo que se necesita para poder aumentar
su número de participantes
les conté dos ejemplos dramáticamente
diferentes el gigantismo de la represa
de itaipú y un proyecto pequeño de 1000
hectáreas en la vereda santelena del
municipio de medellín
pero estos dos proyectos
contando con el del agua potable de mi
papá tienen en común las mismas
características
a mí me gusta mucho hay un profesor
filósofo norteamericano que se llama
john rawls él en el año 70 empezó a
entender que la filosofía había que
conectarla con el mundo
y escribió un libro muy famoso que se
llama el problema de la justicia
en este libro él dice la justicia no es
sólo imparcialidad
hay que mantener la justicia entre las
generaciones
la generación pasada tuvo grandes
responsabilidades con lo que hoy tenemos
nosotros tenemos grandes
responsabilidades con el futuro cuando
el profesor rol se escribió este libro
estamos hablando ya hace más de 50 años
el problema que se enfrentaba el mundo
era el del futuro
y ya yo me hago esta reflexión si
queremos hablar de justicia de las
generaciones en esta época donde los
papás
pueden durar 90 o más años donde ya no
tienen 12 hijos pues quiero decirle a
todos estos jóvenes que están aquí que
ya su responsabilidad no es solamente
con el futuro su responsabilidad ya hoy
también es con el pasado
porque tienen una responsabilidad de
devolverle a quienes tanto les hemos
dado
el profesor roll se dedica mucho a eso
pero hay un es físico inglés es un autor
muy conocido llama duncan green
él dice que él además de haber estudiado
física en oxford viajo
américa latina y entendió
cómo se mueve la sociedad y dice la
sociedad no se mueve cómo se mueve la
física la acción
no genera la consecuencia ve
tiene una teoría que a mí me gusta mucho
sobre los poderes y dice el poder es
mucho más allá que el poder visible
cuando usted quiere hacer una
transformación social
mire el poder invisible mire esa
cantidad de fuerzas que evitan que las
cosas cambien mire qué es lo que está
obligando al statu quo
esta teoría de los poderes y esta teoría
del profesor duncan green sobre el
cambio
implica que quienes queremos transformar
tenemos que aceptar definitivamente los
cambios sociales son lentos los cambios
sociales son constantes los cambios
sociales no son previsibles cuanto se ha
demorado por ejemplo la era de la
tecnología yo no he sido capaz de llegar
a ella
tengo que recurrir a otros aunque estoy
en ella es muy difícil aceptar esos
cambios tan veloces para una comunidad
entonces
y viviendo desde mi mundo laboral
de una persona como yo que he podido
tener acceso a lo que tradicionalmente
se conoce como poder lo que el profesor
duncan llama el poder visible
pienso que definitivamente el poder
tiene sentido solo en estas cuatro
palabras que yo quise resumir
tiene sentido si es para incidir en el
es decir cuál es su idea usted qué
quiere lograr
tiene sentido para incidir con ninguna
idea se logra solo ya vimos ejemplos de
cuántas generaciones han tenido que
pasar para que avisé a una realidad
itaipú se da una realidad
tiene sentido solo para hay que incidir
para decir cuáles son los resultados que
yo quiero cuál es el cronograma cuáles
son los recursos que necesito y por
último incidir sobre los poderes
visibles es decir las leyes el alcalde
el gobernador el presidente el
vicepresidente no sé qué pero realmente
ese poder de incidir
tiene que tener muchas variables
han pasado 60 años y estoy segura que
aquí he estado en mi papá todavía
diciendo que hay que seguir
transformando son muchas las comunidades
que necesitan agua potable
y quiero dejarles un solo mensaje
todos absolutamente todos tenemos el
poder para transformar
yo en mi posición apenas estoy
cumpliendo un pedacito de esa línea
quienes me antecedieron cumplieron en un
pedacito quienes siguen tendrán que
cumplir pero tengan la certeza que el
poder de transformar está en cada uno de
nosotros y es una responsabilidad muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]